a Ukrainian President Vladimir zlenski
says a Russian missile strike in the
city of kramatosk has killed one person
I'm coming to us because you can see
there is just under an hour away from
the Eastern Frontline city buckmut which
has been almost completely destroyed in
near constant shelling zelenski says
three people wounded as well and six
buildings were damaged in the attack he
said these buildings were residential
and again accused moscow's troops of
targeting civilians well Al jazeera's
Hassan Masood joins us now live from
kamatosk Hassan can you tell us a little
more about this missile strike I
understand this is an area where many
people have tried to leave or evacuate
this area is a residential area here in
Crematory in Donetsk region this time
the missile
attacked this area that is in the center
of chromatarsk and as we can see the
shelling hit several buildings at least
nine buildings were attacked by this
missile attack this morning people were
living here sleeping here and starting
their morning some people are left
already in the area and other people
were living in this area that caused one
person killed and at least seven injured
in this attack here in chromatorsk this
shelling that happened here is one of a
number of shelling that is hitting the
areas and the this region west of bakmut
where the fights continued between the
Ukrainian forces and the Russian forces
there the Ukrainian forces say that they
are repelling attacks and a number of
towns around bakmut and the shelling
continues between both sides also other
shelling happened in the days before in
slaviansk the city close to here to
chromatarsk in Donetsk region and also
other cities like constantinifka as
being child all the time and these areas
are in west of bakmut while also the
general staff of Ukrainian forces said
that the Ukrainian forces repelled
attacks toward the south and west of
bakmud also not only here the shelling
also was announced in the south of
Ukraine especially in Odessa while the
military administration of Odessa said
that four missiles were targeting the
coast of Odessa they were hit but these
methods caused some damage at the coast
damaged several buildings there and one
school as the military of the
administration a military of
administration in Odessa said and
announced
a very long Frontline indeed Al
jazeera's Hassan Masood there for us on
the ground in chromatosk in Ukraine
thank you Hassan